okay for those people joining the
livestream this is one of an infinite
series of meetings discussing
incremental development of the Wolfram
language so first item for today
expression object so this is a way of
handling indirectly referenced objects
in the language and we've had a number
of these in internal internally
available for a long time like the bag
stuff so who's here who can talk about
how the bag stuff works this is Rob and
yeah basically it it works it works as
far as you set up you set up this thing
called a bag and then you stuff elements
into it and then you you get the parts
from it that's accessible as so and well
yes that's that uses the same mechanism
oh sorry
or sophisticated okay so the basic idea
here was a create expression object
where you say what the expression is and
you say what type of thing is being
created it then creates something with a
UUID right am i making sense
I said maybe okay so then the idea is
that you are able to and I don't know
exactly what this is all about
expression object apply so let's look at
the stuff bag type things how do those
work well it's it's far back but you do
you do something like you know bag
internal backtick bag open closed open
closed yep and then you do internal
backtick stuff bag of bag comma thing
okay if I say here if I say that table
that I 20 will be just stuffing oh I see
what the return is no since its but if
you do if you know type bag so it's
modifying that that bag in place all
right how do I get the bag out remember
its internal try internal bag part of
bad comma oh that's my best memory of it
yeah okay alright okay so a lot of what
we want to do with expression object is
both this incremental addition like a
linked list or something or a somebody
the summer school implemented a min min
heap data structure okay I'm sorry
we have a data structure implement and
it is a it is a min heap okay to this
bag to this bag stuff in and that you
modify it in place okay well how do you
access that give me a couple of minutes
and I'll find the context it's in so
we've got a bunch of these things is
what you're telling me yes yes so what I
want to do is package them all up and
you know at the beginning expression
object would just support the ones we
already have
they're making sense
well then then we go and implement more
of them but I want to try to understand
what are the operations that you can do
here well that would depend on the data
structure which is the first problem
okay and second of all I think
expression object is a terrible name for
this why
because an expression object should be
an object representing an expression and
this is you know this is a pointer to a
data structure which is which is not
really an expression no but it's it's it
is you should be able to get out of it
the ordinary expression that corresponds
to this thing this data structure it
doesn't correspond to it to an
expression that's the whole point no no
but but the point is not that the point
is these are merely hints the idea there
is always an expression underneath there
is always an expression to which this
can be converted these represent hints
and an implementation that is different
from the usual expression implementation
that's the idea that you would never get
something here where there is no way to
make an expression version of it but
none of these things are actually
expression I'm well aware of that I'm
saying this is a thing that indirectly
represents an expression just as well
don't necessarily know exactly what the
internal implementation of a sparse
array is doesn't matter it represents an
array of a certain type yes and you're
correct if you do if you do for example
input form of bag at any given instance
it has a it has an expression you know
there's a corresponding expression
representation well that's nice but I
don't think that's necessary even for
this functionality okay converted sorry
Dan I couldn't understand yours does
input form do expert bag to expert or
something mm-hmm okay okay fine which is
not probably that that's surplus to
requirements I don't think that's how it
should work I think this should act like
a pointer and the
only thing you should get that is a UUID
well it needs to have some functionality
like that because if you want to send
them if you want to send this this thing
over math okay why having a single name
for the potentially very different
objects because for example we could say
that even sparse array could fit here
somehow so why not having separate heads
for the different objects because I
think it's a big mess I think we want to
collect together this thing which is
essentially an expression with certain
advisory features about how it's going
to be you know how it's how it's going
to be implemented but the operations
that each one will accept will be
potentially different I understand that
I understand that so we need to talk
about that right there could be I mean
that seems one thing I see is nice about
this is there could be a documented way
of getting out what operations are
available yes and I think we want this
to be lightweight I think it wants to be
the case that one can eventually have 50
different data structures here that you
know can be documented in their own you
know just like we documented formats and
things this will be another thing like
that making sense I wonder about this
though is what's the you know what's the
integration with with the GNU Compiler
right so which is perhaps I can make my
point clear right but I would expect
expression object to be something listen
you compiler where you have a
representation of an expression you're
going to compile and not something which
is just a pointer to something which is
is not again an expression I don't
understand you know the way the compiler
works it's just taking a piece of code
or whatever and just doing the
compilation I mean it no no it doesn't
that converts it to a normalized
expression which represents the
underlying expression and then it
possibly compiles that in any one of
I'm aware but I mean I'm okay whatever I
personally think this is the right name
to this I think is the name people will
understand because I think well no
people will not understand this Stephen
that's just wrong Stephen let me finish
my sentence and frankly nobody else on
this call had any idea what expression
objects are supposed to be so in fact
people do not understand this okay what
do you be cold well it could be called
something like you know data structure
oh why not
it's represented you want it to
represent the particular data structure
no no the way to think about this as far
as I'm concerned is the thing is a
pointer to an expression it's not a
pointer to an expression it is
expressions well that's that's debatable
they're wrong expressions look the point
about it is okay let's not get hung up
on the name I I really do think this is
the right name but let's not get hung up
on the name but the more important
issues are you know I'm gonna keep
calling at this and you're gonna keep
saying it's wrong and we're gonna
iterate that in a few minutes okay you
know the the more important issues are
you know how do you do operations on it
so let's imagine you have the thing it's
you know you've okay do we do we agree
that the basic point is that whatever
the thing is called create you know that
this is something which goes from a
normal expression which starts with a
normal expression and no I don't agree
with that because I know how a normal
expression maps onto any of these things
well that's the whole point every one of
these things has to have an expression
form that
the rule there is a normal expression
version of anything that we're gonna
deal with here right that's that's the
serialization but maybe but that's we're
not gonna have something which has I
mean we go so serializing wxf but that's
a different thing but we're not gonna
have something which doesn't have an
expression form and the only thing that
concerns me here is that you might want
to start from nothing like you might
want to start with a bag that has
nothing in it but you could just use you
know bag of empty or whatever you know
whatever its its name is in this this
context or something just like you did
above well what do you mean I see so
that's I don't think that's right
because I think that's I mean maybe
that's right but but basically the point
is the idea here is everything has an
expression okay okay so a principle here
sure sure sure show us an example of an
expression that corresponds to these
things okay the principle everything has
a corresponding expression which may be
you know internally the implementation
is completely different but for example
over here okay over here the you know
over here the expression is the list 1 2
3 or something ok so what I would
imagine in this case that's crazy you've
converted the bag to a line I know the
thing I keep on saying is everything has
a corresponding expression we're not
dealing with things it has a
corresponding expression it is the
choice of expression object how it
represents the thing internally and
that's what the second argument
determines like for example it could
choose to take a list and represent it
as a linked list internally
nothing that seems fine to me that
doesn't make any sense
why it just doesn't I mean the suppose
it's a heap what suppose you give the
this this list to a heap you know what
does that even mean I mean it could it
could like the compiler does with that
when it doesn't know what to do it has
some some default method which is
probably sorting the normal expression
somehow the question is what do you
expect it okay so let's take a heap as
an example what are the operations that
you're going to want to do on the heap
right you can you can add a note the
leader node and and you can keep a PHY
right those are the only three things
you can keep before it's order delete
okay so my point of view about this just
like we represent sets as lists with
Union and so on being the thing that
does the reordering so similarly here
the heap is a list and the ordering of
that list
no well typically binary tree I
understand that I understand that when
you serialize it your serializing it in
some form that comes out as presumably a
list but you can't recover the the heat
from the list fine
yeah I mean it would be a tree probably
the you know probably this should be our
new tree object right tree element
whatever it is right that's probably the
right correspondence here but otherwise
that the whole point is there's got to
be an expression form and there's got to
be a reasonable lossless round trip
between the expression and this external
data structure right but in the case of
all these data structures right the
form you know the faith of fake form
which in the case of sparse array is not
that fake because it's really just no
entry although it has extra bits in it
which we don't need to get into it right
that form right is a complete
representation that's unique to that
thing right so the sparse array right
has a very specific structure this
internal bag right it has the bag head
around around the list they don't know
what the input form of the heap data
structure we have is I'm trying to
figure that out and integrate they think
it's in a great context and again these
things yes we don't have documentation
for it if you don't use them you don't
remember how they work another question
is so so it is claimed all right so
let's make a list here existing internal
data structure my existing you mean
accessible through the top level or just
anything in C pretty much either because
I think anything that is easy you know
ie ie easy to expose then those are the
ones that already exist at comp love
give you a list of those now so the bag
okay
keep okay hash table and I think that's
the some of it what about ones that have
easy appending don't we have things
which are lists which are easier
hardness that's an egg okay do we have
linked list or not we have lots of
linked lists data structures inside the
kernel but none that are set up for
top-level that probably wouldn't be
that's doable and clearly we'd want that
if we were going to do this thing
the link lists you can if he does like a
double exist you can take elements off
off and so yes I mean we can actually do
that with bag now although it's it's no
no we don't want to do that the whole
point here is we're offering people if
you give the right advisory data
structure you will get an optimally
efficient thing and bag is basically a
stack right it's it's an array it's it's
an array of storage factors okay it's
growable and there's a way that bag can
be used to emulate a linked list I've
shown it before in some notes but it's
okay so I want to go back again to what
people are going to do so the the claim
is that every one of these has a
corresponding status expression
structure okay so for bag the
corresponding structure is just a list
you know simple list right mm-hmm okay
for a hash table what is the
corresponding structure basically it's a
list of pairs so that the key key value
pairs okay so it probably should be an
association yes that could be an
association what about collisions in the
hash table it's still an association of
keys and values you're not showing you
know they map into the hash table as an
association fine there's there's only a
single entry so it's safe so if two keys
are identical you can only have right so
we need a magic head for you know
collided entries or something no because
they're not in the hash table each I
what do you mean they're not in the hash
table you have a key not saying you
can't have collisions I'm saying you
can't have two our elements with the
same key the key is the unique thing and
that the key is determined that keys are
determined to be identical by something
hash tolerance
which is the same as same coutureness so
basically they're there they're equal if
they're same queue okay well she
collision question mark key collisions
probably okay probably probably handled
probably already had that correct yes
okay um okay heap what if the
corresponding expression I would say I
would say a list some of the the heap
has a you know he's got some option to
sort of you know with in with an entry
it could probably also be a list of list
of pairs like you know key comma so you
might want to order a bunch of values
according to the keys so again we could
either take a list or an association
that either would work yeah I mean he he
is a tree right so no it's really just a
table list of flat list what I mean by a
heap an ordered he the min he then
ordered heap is just a flat list it's a
list where your your child is either 2
or 2 2 times away from you or 2 x + 1
that's the so is this actually a min
heap yes no it doesn't have to be a me
it can be you know it's it's a binary
heap is what dance function can be
whatever you want it to be right right
right
the natural structure of the heap is as
a tree not really nobody nobody wants to
implement or efficiently does it as a
tree yeah I mean the tree a tree is the
inefficient way of doing a he but but
that would be the natural way to input
that finally the data structure will
abstract that into a good implementation
so how its implemented
it's a different issue ASIC let's take
that okay separate is maybe okay alright
so let's talk about so everything has a
corresponding expression and there's the
question of how do you put it into this
optimized internal form how do you refer
to that form how do you get it out how
do you operate it in that for operate on
it in that form okay that makes sense
yeah operator on the internal form you
mean yes
so I mean operations so the basic first
operation is you know create expression
object or something like that okay I
don't know exactly how that create the
thing the next thing is convert to
normal expression we should use normal
for that probably we could yeah and
another one is operate on it on the
expression object need an API for you
know each type of expression which is
fine well is that is that how it should
work I mean so okay so this would be
normal of let's imagine okay so the next
question is in serialization okay let's
so let's imagine that what actually
happens here is that create expression
object which I'm not certain I'm not
super happy with the I mean maybe the
right thing to do is this to create an
expression object and the type is first
and the initial form is second and
optional okay and then this returns an
expression object which has presumably a
UUID presumably that's what it displays
or does it display as as a as a
so-called it I blob not wishing to to
inflame it I any further they'll call it
a summary box I think a summary box
would be useful because you want to know
you don't really care about it's your ID
that much except deserve
well maybe doesn't have a UID maybe it
actually maybe the input form of this
thing is
byte array or some other weird thing
doesn't really matter what the input
form is so long as it's reconstructed Oh
so for example if we create two with the
same input do we consider the times
thank you
yeah no no you should not consider
because you know like if you created two
bags that have exactly the same input
and you stuffed in one not the other oh
yeah so that's what oh I see but but
they would be different because their
expression object with its byte array or
whatever would be different right
because every time you operate on it see
one thing that's key for these is one
every time you operate on one of these
things it's serialization or expression
representation actually changes yes but
but the other still same queue if they
contain the same data right that is
correct if you if you do the bag and the
bag is a bag of one two three and
they're both a bag of one two three then
they will be thank you yes you could you
could that's that's that can become hard
to implement but it's probably not
actually true right now like for some
for some cases it is not for other cases
we have an operation for comparing these
structure three different operation
because one thing is compare the whole
structure and another compare the
content which is what Jose was claiming
always work as you you are so same queue
could operate by doing the by getting
the input form via comparing that that's
obviously grossly expensive well there's
the same content same queue right and if
it had you you IDs then it's clear
they're not going to be same queue
that's right one possibility would be
that the thing actually has the form has
a UUID together with either
hidden on non hidden you know byte array
or something I mean it can display as a
I mean okay there's another point here
which is okay we also need delete object
to work right delete object will clear
the storage associated with the with the
expression object make sense
it's deleting it the same as freeing it
like like to take back with no content
the question is what happens if you said
X equals expression object and then you
say delete object on the expression
object still have you still have this
expression object with the same UUID but
that UID is no longer active so if you
try to do an operation on it we give a
warning saying this this expression
object it's been deleted it's no longer
then we need a clear because we need a
way of clearing up to fill it again well
now you just create a new one operate on
the object so so one question is I mean
so the output of this if you pasted that
into a cell and input cell what would
happen there it would give the summary
blob that's not the question the
question is if you took the the summary
blob and pasted it into an input cell
and hit shift enter what happens and
also so let's assume you can reconstruct
it in a given session then it presumably
will not will it be reconstructed belén
the future session
a lots good question with the UUID that
by the way we got a bunch of background
noise cuz I was around you put yourself
on mute um I would suggest we not have
these things referred to we have summary
boxes that or not they're not
reproducible because the problem is the
summary box stores the current data then
you change it then it's it's not gonna
be what you expect well we've got
dynamic summary boxes but I don't even
know how they work
you
even though I agree with that so if you
have the summary box evaluate it at some
point and then you change the this same
UID object are you going to update that
other summary box or not but anyway you
cannot copy that because okay
can I can I talk for a second about how
to append to a bag how to stuff more
stuff into a bag okay
I'm kind of wondering I don't know what
the heck this is what is this operators
only OHS what the heck is this it's
something you wrote and then of us
understand great okay so this was an
idea of having certain operations
available there another possibility is
that you should be able to do that you
should essentially have our brat values
on an expression object that are
differently different for different
structures here what do we think about
that idea is that a stupid idea or not
so that's one possibility
another possibility is something more
like this
I would certainly prefer the first one
if we can make it work where for each
type we basically document what you know
because in fact with this first version
yeah with this first version it's pretty
nice because what would happen is you
could simply say x equals expression
object and then this would just speed it
up basically as opposed to I mean
another question here is how this ruler
wouldn't you want that to be a pen to
those Stephen creating the open - yes
what no a pen - changes the object in
place now but but it could with this yes
because this has a UUID so append a pen
would imply creating a new expression
object with that thing added to it which
i think is not what you would want right
right and I'm sorry I'm jumping back a
little bit but right I'm thinking maybe
we want the input form to be just you
know the UUID and you know that's we
could start that in the summary box and
then any time you evaluate it in the you
know in that given session it'll find
that expression object and work but then
we would need to have a nice failure
message for when you try it again in the
future kernel session to say sorry
which
yeah I think that's just fine the only
question is whether for serialization
you want the input form I mean are you
suggesting that the things would not be
movable from session to session well not
not without some work on your part
I guess it's my initial suggestion one
way clearly would work is to just say
create expression object yeah I mean if
you say creative expression objects of
the type comma normal of the old
expression object then that would
certainly make you a new one
right so one right so yeah I mean I
guess we could conceivably have an
explicit input form you know shows
everything and and maybe we have an
input form that shows everything it
doesn't have the UUID right that's
exactly where I was heading that may be
the I'm not sure what full form would do
but input form would have the data or
with it I guess full form should be the
full funny version of the input form
then the output form in standard form
you know showed the UUID well I mean the
standard form can be a blob but
basically all it stores is the UUID and
then on reinterpretation if you're no
longer in the same session it says sorry
and if you want to save the input form
you need to explicitly send the input
form all right so let's just look here
at all the append to type operations
okay
so what does this thing a mystical fizz
with a pen - because it's its hold first
so if we have x equals expression object
and we say a pen - X comma 45 that's not
gonna work yeah that's not gonna work
why because what you will do is to
evaluate X create a new expression
object with a 45 appended and and
reassign that new expression object to X
that's not probably need to do this and
see any way we could you know have it
put in a case where if exit
it's an expression object that doesn't
reset X that it just resets the
expression object but somehow I paint
who needs to know what X s that's right
that will always evaluate X at some
point right so if X evaluate an
expression object that can say oh I'm
going to I think that's a bit hacky if I
might say so I mean because let me
consider a couple of other cases that
seem awkward to me so another one will
be rest of an expression object what
does it return by the way why does rest
not have a default the way that first
has a default why does it have no second
argument because rest it returns a list
not an element this is broken again yes
we feed that's why we rejected it we can
we talked about this and we explicitly
rejected it okay fine but showing many
of these list operations use return the
normal list for these objects many of
these cases yeah well know if they can
avoid it but are you going to create a
new every time sue is this many of these
things should operate in place okay
and actually the correct form that's
what this expression object apply is all
about okay that's what this is about yes
so it's saying
do fpdc1 yeah so every time you want to
append you need to create a pure
function that's what this is saying I
mean it may not be the most beautiful
way to do it but that's what this is
saying but really basic operations like
a Penta to have its own form I want
maybe but what is it it's not an append
to
because the pen too is hold first it's a
version of a pen - that isn't hold first
yeah in some sense that's an argument
for that last line you have having you
know having commands that work for a
particular type of Russian because and a
pen makes sense for bags prepend makes
no sense with all four the bags does
however a doubly-linked list so
different things like very and I think
if we do them with strings like that
then we could have something expression
object of bags you know commands or
functions or something like that most of
this is that this is really a low-level
you know thing and most of this will
actually happen automatically through
the compiler eventually right it's just
thing to say maybe we should have a
compiler person in the next conversation
about this like have api's basically for
these so maybe this is the way that we
initially do it and we maybe support
something which is essentially a
compilation later all right let's turn
to some of the rather discussions for
today and let's that's plan to schedule
another piece on expression objects
maybe a custom meeting meeting including
some compiler folk ok good ok onward ok
so any more
Thanks ok yes this is a feature is paid
for and immediate location
hopefully my updated Mars it's
insufficient ok you're asking can I
make a geolocation a random geolocation
on Mars is this not is this in the bill
it it is in the GIS context and it has a
dual model option so you just say to
your modern customers this is arguably a
very peculiar thing where did it come
from why don't we apply to be invent
this because it's very useful for
examples in geo world in the same way
that there is random point so we keep
needing yeah it's a random point with
respect to the geoid fix right with the
correct distribution as opposed to a
flat you know a flat space distribution
by so North Pole is rare so to speak
here exactly the by default this is
uniform in area and then yes we can see
in the earth page it has another
argument to specify in which projection
it should be uniform okay okay that's
cool okay so if I say it's your position
random geolocation geo model I mean
actually you might as well just put does
this work captured okay and eventually
you'll be able to say random astro
location anywhere in the universe right
with some bizarre metric that determines
you know how volume measure for the
universe never mind it could get very
confusing okay I'm still waiting for the
update here working so yeah so the this
function has three arguments the first
one is the region the second one is the
number or dimensions and the third one
and well it's actually now the second is
the projection in which it should to be
universe if I could
yes so that's there is a slightly newer
version but so if I say random to your
location of France for example did you
get a point in France
well that's cool and France comma
hundred you get a hundred points in
France you can look at some examples
forever yeah that's interesting the
motivation for calling into random
geolocation rather than the opposition
is because when you specify a projection
like here you get a geo grid position
back which is with a projection in which
it's uniform and this is important
because depending on the projection you
are going to use for the math you may be
interested in one projection I mean
surely it could be zero position it
could be but it is a pity that we are
creating points in a Mercator projection
and we have to convert them back to geo
position we prefer to keep them in the
Geo grid position form because it's
projection in which they were generated
and in which they look homogeneous you
see that square there I'm confused why
don't you just turn I think it's
confusing but it's random geolocation
I think it should be random geo position
even if it might be can return in a geo
grid position in certain cases your
positions will be very strange if you
return again a random geo grid position
yeah
well that's still at your position it
just happens that the word grid in the
middle point looks like too much like a
primitive I think yeah
can it return anything other than single
positions can't return regions current
not of region it can return that your
position array like yeah with a thousand
points or an array of ten by ten by ten
okay explain to me again why when it's
in and by the way I'm surprised you just
say Mercator naked here that you're not
saying geo projection error Mercator yes
that's something with disgust original
it was a projection but we thought that
it's strange to return something with
different heads controlled by a
projection by an option so that's why we
prefer to have it more like I still
don't understand why you want that
different head well because they if you
are interested in having points which
are uniform in a given projection like
here in the market a projection then
it's more natural to return them as
Mercator points rather than lateral
points because that's a preferred
projection for them so in most
applications you will want them already
in that projection so we don't want to
spend time going to your positions and
then in your applications you have to go
back again I think it's a fine thing to
have as an option and maybe it's the
default if you've given a chair
projection other Mercator you get your
grid position rather than to your
position out I think it's a detail I
think it's the typical case you're going
to want is a bunch of geo positions or
geo grid positions doesn't matter
because all of our geo functions take
both your position and your grid
position yes but if they are if they
have too many they would have to spend
time doing other information no I'm
suggesting don't do the transformation
as soon as you've said geo projection is
anything other than well the default is
what is equiangular or something is that
right
effectively positions right yes which
are uniform on the surface of the earth
which is not
associated to any projection so there's
no natural value perhaps none but it
looks ugly you don't have a projection
corner so that's why the argument also
looks better we just don't give an
argument I don't buy that because
there's got to be a default value for
the argument as well what does it mean
that okay so the issue is yeah so geo
projection I think it would make more
sense to say geo projection arrow none
means you're not projecting and that
returns geo positions and your
projection arrow a projection it will
return a geogrid position with respect
to that projection mm-hm
so you'll find with returning different
heads controlled by yeah because yes in
this case because they are eaten by geo
functions in exactly the same way if the
heads were were different you know I
think that's okay now I mean coming back
to I really like the idea the
parallelism of having a geo projection
in the random GOP position that mirrors
the geo projection in Geographics and so
on now I also think that this case we
should call it all not world and I also
wonder whether both should work I think
if you say Mars
it should presumably do that directly
without you having to say to your model
of that if world works then Mars should
work interesting world is
and interpreted always as also you can
say world come at your mother goes to
Mars sorry what do you think well yes
world doesn't mean earth always world
means all so you could say come at your
mother goes to Mars okay that works into
graphics for someone does this need of
random seeding function I've forgotten
what a convention now is for the random
functions here I don't think so okay
fine okay it's cool now what's this
dimensions thing yes it means it can be
either n or at least n1 comma into the
previous two cases oh I see I see I see
but the projection thing I just don't
believe and I think that should be a GL
projection obviously especially also
because I think it ambiguity I'm making
the second argument ambiguous seems
totally weird but this is cool and it's
particularly cool the way that you can
do it in with a particular I mean I'm
I'm not totally sold on the lat/long
this thing here don't we have a better
way to specify those bounding boxes well
yes you can specify a do primitive like
idea like I do bounce region oh you can
say world or multiple ways yeah this is
okay I'm not sure how important that
cases not very important I yeah it
because we have it in the elevation data
fair enough yeah that's reasonable
enough all right this is cool yep okay
um okay we're running out of time here
but let me um can we did somebody have a
brilliant idea about ARF no not really
we have comments from a user defending
that this should be associated to never
and they replace family and I wanted
only to point out that me
that is a going to be a bit problematic
because Michael is working on by a
strand which is very DNA related so I
find a bit strange that we add a mutate
add and it's not related to by strand
sorry
a mere trait last suggestion for the
name of ours was mutated
right which has neither nothing to do
either with expression object or with
biology so it's a kind of a strange name
yes it was this function that was able
to extract a Safin list operate on it
and put it back yes oh right right right
right right right
it's the thing for doing yes it came out
of a discussion in quantum computing
right I'm not buying the mutate at being
a biology problem I think if we add
functions to manipulate DNA it's going
to be strange that mutant doesn't work
there it's totally different
well you don't usually I mean a mutation
you're talking about you know like a
snip might like put a snip in I don't
think what would want to call that
mutate at but anyway I think it's some
yeah actually this was a really nice
function the function is good it's just
the name is difficult not yet do we have
a description of what it does somewhere
here what was the user suggestion here
that the name should be associated to
replace it should be a variety of the
place this user sees the function very
much through replace is it correct well
we discussed that it's a mixture of
replace and mud
families so yeah I would have to page
and it's been long enough that I forgot
exactly what the user says but yes we
didn't find it crazy but my recollection
is the wasn't quite right in my opinion
so this was so something like one two
three four positions two and four apply
I can't be F it has to be apply
everywhere so something we are fine well
this isn't the correct implementation
yeah I think you had you had your
implementation in the previous section
but this was more less any study notes
Mississippi coded there was all notes
dis implement implementation work and it
scurrying like this
yeah probably we can have it both ways
with three arguments and with two
arguments there was also the discussion
of whether there's the second argument
should be a list of integers or a list
of positions or a list of lists of
integers no the the most common case is
one level list so we should support that
I think it should be like this or I mean
this is always pass no it isn't no it's
not it can be any subset
okay what about something like subset
map so so this is a function which is
this combination of the mat in action
and then they're replacing back and
that's our main I understand nothing on
to a subset sum close to yes that was
the other but I listened with we had I
remember I was suggesting something
starting is very reconstruct three
something the difference between map hat
and this is that it this pulls in I mean
this is okay so another one is like
multiple map at it doesn't have the same
structure as my pet so it has map at you
know like if I say something like this
and then map at has to have this thing
here right or does it not need that can
it do that yes you can't do that yes but
if you put a list of integers its
interpreted as a single position yes
spans like all comma something or
something more complex with some care
because span is a part is back another
position spec and my part takes position
specs I mean like but first of all is so
Sandra livestream is asking about spans
and things like this
and that I implement this thing here
execute that well replace part also
takes position specs so things that are
participating may not work well we shall
not mix it parts position aspects with
its parts pic right right okay but but
but the subset map name doesn't seem
hopeless to me because it is like map in
the sense that I mean map puts things
back into the structure right I see what
ring so sorry it gives the same
instructor you know always which this
does as well
I like subset map I mean if you saw that
in piece of code it's not utterly
incomprehensible I mean what you would
see is something like subset map well I
mean this is a this is quite obscure
because this will be a curried form this
is not crazy I think I like this I do
prefer it to mutate that it is a map
yeah it is another map it is a map on
subset of the elements right
listen let's go ahead and implement and
put a ref page in for subset map okay
see how it flies flies all right should
wrap this up um okay so next time we
need to have a custom meeting about
expression object there was a request on
our live stream for a for a live stream
review of the compiler maybe we will
provide that since the compiler was
mentioned here and we'll have to cover
this next time yep right thanks to
everybody on live stream thanks to
everybody on the voice Channel and
torchy Olson bye